[Music]
a lot of people have been
worrying about inflation incessantly
it's america's biggest problem right now
inflation's at about seven percent
highest it's been in many many years and
people are feeling a pinch this is a
real thing if you've been to the gas
pump you've been to the grocery store
you've been to chipotle you're like why
is my chicken bowl now ten dollars i
didn't even get the guac john i didn't
get that that would have been another 11
this is insane and so i've been digging
into just kind of helpful ways i like to
call them hacks you hate the word hacks
because they're not hacks it takes a
little bit of work it takes a little bit
of research know-how time effort energy
so hacks just make me feel like it's
easy even though it's not that's a very
millennial approach i i accept that is
where we stand so i wanted to give the
people out there some tips especially
around grocery shopping because the
stats are showing us people are spending
you know it used to be 292 a month now
it's 350 a month yeah on groceries and
so there's some ways that i've i've been
living this way before it was cool i was
the original hipster when it came to
frugality and so there's a lot of ways
people are overspending when it comes to
groceries eating out is a whole other
thing right when it comes to that meat
really expensive right now i'm not going
to tell people to go eat tofu because we
live in a society john
because we don't hate cheese this used
to be a real country i'm not eating that
stuff
but here's the thing one of the biggest
ways people overspend is like we talk
about college choice as one of the
biggest ways to make college affordable
grocery store choice
man that's a game changer some of y'all
shopping at whole foods or whole
paycheck whatever you want to call it
that's a budget buster right now maybe
we try out aldi
no it's not the fanciest store you got
to put the quarter in the cart it's very
old-timey and fun you just put a quarter
in the car a quarter to get the cart and
then you get the quarterback when you
put the cart back oh just in case you
get an efficiency no it's an efficiency
thing they don't have to have a cart
person you are the cart person you are
the car person they charge you you know
10 cents for a bag they save some money
that way anyways you can get some great
prices there to get all your necessities
i'm a big fan of trader joe's if you
have one in your area i can fill up a
whole little buggy at trader joe's and
spend less than a hundred bucks you can
have a shopping spree and it's a it's a
great deal but another thing people need
to do is buy generic
and this is offensive to some people so
don't take away my oreos absolutely
offended right now you're like oh do you
want me to get sugar rounds
you want me to get the far out fruities
instead of fruity pebbles that's exactly
right but here's the truth john most of
those products are made in the same
factories in the same lines with the
same ingredients you can buy the look
next to the cheerios and you buy the
just the cellophane bag of oat o's yeah
right you know it comes in the bag you
get worried you have to get a box that's
right like it feels a little less secure
and stable i will say milk in a bag is
disconcerting not gonna have it i just
want it and a carton but that's a big
way people can save is going generic uh
i know there's some deal breakers there
like toilet paper i'm going name brand
i'm sorry i have trust issues deodorant
not i'm not uh i'm not hedging on that
one you're not going with the with the
dollar general branded i am a snob when
it comes to deodorant you smell great i
appreciate that it's working thank you
another thing to do is buy things in
bulk that you naturally would eat a lot
of right so buying a huge bag of rice
from costco that could be a great deal
that's going to feed your family for a
long time
but people assume that buying in bulk
means a better deal and the truth is it
doesn't here's what i want you to do
it's a quick fun little math experiment
you take your phone out when you're at
the grocery store
divide the price by the
well now you're ounces people to do work
george and i just want to go to the
grocery store they're not really hacks
are they john sounds like you're making
me do math yes but that math is going to
make your life better because you're not
going to feel inflation as much i have a
six-year-old i mean sixth grade son and
he working through math and he asked the
other day when am i ever gonna use this
and now you're telling him in the
grocery store yep i'm telling hank buddy
there's hope for you
you will use this i think that's
disconcerting not the pythagorean
theorem but just basic math uh this is
so do the math on those ounces don't
assume it's a good deal because it's at
the wholesale club and you're buying it
in bulk that's a big one and there's
this new thing called shrink flation
that is driving me crazy personally
so if your your breakfast bars used to
be one and a half ounces oh yes is that
what it's called yes now
they're charging the same price but they
shrunk it down to one ounce instead of
one and a half ounces i opened a bag of
something recently and i i thought
it was all air i looked i'd like look in
and say you grew yeah like it's amazing
it's a big friendly giant like the bfg
what is happening so it's called shrink
flashing shrink flashing it's a real
thing
yeah and companies are doing this to
save money without changing their price
because if you go well my breakfast bars
were you know i like lara bars we like
those we eat those and you go it used to
be five bucks well now larabars shrunk
the ounces and charge the same five
dollars so that you never notice you're
none the wiser john you're just a little
more hungry this is how they get you
they got me so there's a lot of ways
obviously meal planning but let me tell
you meal planning is a lot for a lot of
people it just feels too aggressive so i
like to say start with foods that you
enjoy that you're willing to eat because
if you're not willing to eat it you know
what happens it goes in the trash and
that's how inflation really gets you you
don't even eat the stuff you bought
because you thought you were going to be
in the mood for kale salad
classic scenario nobody's in the good
fridge and then you go we're getting
pizza tonight that's right well
i i think it's important to also say and
i know this people are going to roll
their eyes and say oh my gosh you're
giving
leftovers our thing
and don't be above leftovers i'm a big
fan of leftovers too we're huge in our
house but um i know that can be
offensive and if you hate leftovers
become a better cook
and then you'll like leftovers it's
amazing how that works shots fired yep
coming at you america there's a whole
bunch of folks out here from chick-fil-a
you guys have done a great job keeping
the prices down so way to go guys big
fan of chick-fil-a i've got my own
chick-fil-a hacks that i'll share it
another time but uh i like to go budget
friendly my wife does not her meal
somehow is like 48 dollars at
chick-fil-a mine's like four dollars i'm
getting the kids meals oh i didn't go
with you toy for
right they understand yeah no i was with
you that one time yep john saw me order
a kid's meal and i was in the car with
him and they thought i was his child
they thought man
don't see a lot of middle schoolers for
the full beard but we'll go with it
here's what it comes down to do a little
bit of math to figure out what is this
meal actually costing me does it cost me
20 per person because that's not a good
way to fight inflation right if i can
get it down to you know three four five
dollars that's a great deal and let's
just call it out like we can we laugh
joke
we we joke and we have a good time
i know that there are people who are
really hurting with the with the food
prices oh absolutely hard yeah and
things were already compressed and tough
and tight millions of people looking for
jobs trying to move jobs people
this is a messy time man and so i just
want to acknowledge it sometimes there's
moments you know when you're working
people's mental health when you're
working people's money
like there's i don't have an instant
solution for you other than to say i'm
sitting here with you i'm sorry and
that's what i mean my solution is let's
get creative and let's make it kind of
fun yeah and at least then it takes a
little bit of that sting away and you
feel like man this kind of what are what
other areas can we do this in another
one is gas that's another thing people
are worried about and you know i use an
app called gas buddy they're not a
sponsor but if you're listening awesome
app that shows me the cheapest gas in my
area and usually it's the wholesale
clubs huh i don't know that sams or
costco and so those are great ways to
just do a little bit of math but don't
go to the gas station 48 miles away to
save two cents a gallon also do the math
on that and go that's not worth it i'm
saving 20 cents to go an extra 20 miles
yeah don't do that either very cool or
stop driving that's a good way to do it
too carpool or carpool a big fan of that
a lot of people that work here at ramsey
in my neighborhood and sometimes i'll
just hit your ride that's hey that to me
is where i like that i like to see
communities come together and say we got
some local challenges what are some
local solutions to some of these
challenges we're going to have people
over once a month back in
when i had a group of friends we had an
event called rotisserie where we just
rotated that's the cheesiest name ever i
know but
we would just have once a week everybody
would take their leftovers out and bring
them over and it'd be half a bottle of
wine
yeah it was an old school potluck and we
just rotated houses the rules were no
one cleans up
we're not like there's laundry in the
floors longer than the floor we want to
hang out and we're going to clean our
fridges out and these are folks that
were way better off financially than me
it wasn't about necessity at that point
it was just about community yeah and it
turned into something that was great
when it financially for us all too right
yeah and this will all blow over so
we're not saying this is your new life
and you have to shop at this new store
and you have to get gas over this is
just to help you guys out during this
time so that you have a little bit more
margin in your budget and that's why we
teach the baby steps by the way because
if you're in debt inflation is hitting
you a lot harder than when you've got
three to six months of expenses sitting
in a savings account you've got no one
you don't know anyone anything
you can sleep at night not worrying
about the extra 20 cents at the pump and
this is gonna blow over and inflation
will regulate back down they'll do
something else to
but don't let intentionality go by the
wayside yeah
i love i love the idea even if it's for
a few cents here a quarter here a couple
dollars here
intentional let this be the moment you
say i'm starting intentionally how i
spend my money whether it's on a bag of
rice or for a car or for a home or
anything in between